hello everybody hope they are good today
is going to be a very important day in
the market and we've been saying this
for quite some time but today we've got
fomc meeting and it's going to be quite
a unique one we're going to go through
it in a minute but let me tell you first
that this video is going to be about
economy we're going to talk about
economics okay and I know that some of
you want me to go into the chart but you
know there are song weeks I've been
telling you this in advance
that you know is difficult to trade look
at the look at these news announcements
okay it's insane you got CPI on Tuesday
CPA by the way became lower than
expected which is good okay because that
means that you know the Federal Reserve
is doing a good job at stopping
inflation although we'll see when they
revise these numbers you know if they
are the same or they change but you know
the previous was four to nine percent
forecast was for the one percent and it
came lower in the forecast because you
can see that that the result was a four
percent okay that's good then today we
got PPI data this is the favorite
measure of inflation for the Federal
Reserve and it also came lower than
expected the forecast was zero to one
percent and it was sorry minus zero to
one percent and the result was minus 0.3
percent
so that's a good thing and today we got
the fomc meeting and it's going to be
quite a unique one because the market is
pricing in
that the Federal Reserve is going to
pause the rates here and they are not
going to hike more okay and what happens
after they post rates well usually you
know they can hold here for some months
sometimes they've been holding for years
and then the pivot then they kind of
start to cut rates we're gonna go
through all of this in this video but
let me show you first the probabilities
that the market is pricing in so here
you can see that the market is pricing
in that they are gonna hold right here
okay that they're gonna pause 92 percent
probabilities only eight percent
probabilities is a red hike
um you may say but is this reliable what
I tell you I've been checking this for
the past fomc meetings and it was quite
reliable so yes I would say that's quite
reliable and even more you know the same
day of the fomc
because yes these numbers change quite
often and quite quickly depending on the
data like CPI non-farm payrolls PPI data
but you know we've got all of that
already we got non-farm payrolls we got
CPI yesterday we got PPI today so the
market is pricing in that they're gonna
pause right here what does that mean
that means that it would be a massive
surprise if they hike another 25 basis
points here okay and if the FED hikes
again today then the market is going to
react very aggressively okay um yeah I
can tell you that the dollar would suit
up to the upside and Bitcoin would drop
very badly but again
that would be a surprise okay the most
likely thing is that the third comes
today and says we're gonna post right
here what I'm gonna hike this month
we're gonna still continue being data
dependent we'll see what happens in the
next month we are not saying that there
might not be new hikes but for now we're
gonna pause here
okay so that's what the market is
anticipating 92 percent probabilities
that they post rates here
but that's not everything we're gonna
get today because that's only this part
federal funds rate okay you can see here
in Forex Factory forecast a pause again
okay that's the most likely thing also
of course there from statement you get
this in order for MC meetings and I
expect that it is at least a couple of
times that they're gonna be data
dependent again
and try to not get you guys euphoric and
think you're gonna start now with the
ballroom no no no they're gonna say
we're gonna pause here but watch out
because there might be new hikes we
don't know that yet okay that's what I
think I want to say bro we're gonna go
later into the big picture and you wanna
see that usually when they push rates
then you know they can wait so months
some years and then they could them they
don't continue hiking that's usually
what happens okay and the most important
thing in my opinion today is going to be
this the fomc economic projections and
the fomc press conference
why that's because I'm also anticipating
that I want to pause hiking here they
are gonna pause the radio at 5 25 okay
so if that's what the market is pricing
in 92 percent
then price wouldn't really move based on
this only okay
because that's what the market is
pricing in if that's what happens but of
course
like in every FMC meeting the press
conference can move price because
um you know the federal funds rate might
stay the same they might post here but
it's also very important to hear that
press conference and the questions and
the answers because that can tell you a
bit you know how the FED is is the fat
dobbish or is the fat hawkish are they
gonna say again that they are not
planning to code rate this year or you
know they're going to be a bit more
relaxed about this and no answer with so
much strength
who knows but that's going to be
important but of course the fomc
economic projections that's the Dot Plot
The Dot Plot is basically a document
that is released four times a year every
three months so that's in March June
September and December and it's very
important because it tells you what the
fomc participants
think that the interest rates are gonna
go in the next years
okay so uh in March that was set in the
22nd of March when they released a Dot
Plot and I think that you know they were
between five percent and 525 percent so
you know if you do the the the the the
median that's around five to ten percent
I think they said that that was gonna be
the top now the top has been five 25
pretty close to it so let's see if in
this new Dot Plot they say the same
that would indicate that this is the top
of the interest rates the top of this
hike cycle or if they change the top I
don't think they're going to I think uh
the Dot Plot is going to be uh the same
at least for the top of the rate cycle I
think this should be the end of this
hike cycle that's what I think at least
I I'm expecting the Dot Plot to be quite
similar to what it was in March at least
in terms of the top okay uh that would
mean that this is the top of the rate
cycle
um you know maybe the pause here for
some months and then they could write
Sunday pivot
because again pivot is not the same as
posing okay when you pause is because
probably something has broken and don't
forget that this is the most aggressive
hike cycle in history they've raised the
500 points in in a year is insane so of
course something has to break so when
they pause this usefully because
something has broken and they need to
pause they need to see uh usually also
because inflation is coming down as it
is which is good news so
um you know let's not make more damage
hiking like mud guys and see where the
economy goes and then if the economy
continues going into that direction and
is you know that's inflationary then
that's when you can quote right
and that's the pivot okay so that's what
I think it's very important to see what
the Dot Plot says and of course the
press conference uh the plan for today
is going to be calm don't have any open
positions today could be a lot of
volatility we're gonna go now also to
the Bitcoin chart do you want to see
that the chart is waiting for this day
okay to see what they say so this is the
Bitcoin chart you can see the you know
nothing is really happening because you
know what inside this range these are
due to resistant zones that you know the
resist and support resistance support
resistance so these two zones here these
dot lines they are in my opinion two key
zones in this range so uh you can see
that the whole week they've been holding
this soon this was the CPI they you can
see price suits up to the upside stop
hunt then they retrace they left that
week here of course this week is going
to get filled sooner or later that's 100
of the week does 50 of the week
so 26 300 has to get filled probably it
gets filled today not gonna lie
um this is the projection that we had uh
from Sunday from the Sunday update in
the case that they post hikes today and
the FED is quite rubbish with dobbish
could be many things could be that they
say straight away I can confirm that we
aren't gonna continue Rising rates then
price would go up I can tell you that or
that they are not that strong about the
possibility of cutting rates and pivot
this year okay in any of these two
scenarios that would be quite obvious
that would be quite bullish and then
price would suit up today okay and hit
these songs of course the 50 of the week
maybe 100 and then start to Target this
zones to the upside all right
um of course if they hike today again 25
basis points
because nobody is expecting that the
market is not pricing that in so the
market would break below this one here
most likely break below this support
here and then you could probably say uh
price going below 25k that's what I
think bro again I don't think that's
very likely so I'm gonna remove this SNL
for now uh what would I go now into the
bigger picture of what happens
historically when the Federal Reserve
pivots
and when they pause so this is the big
picture I posted this chart on Twitter
this morning we were talking about it so
um some of you were asking me to bring
this to YouTube so I could explain
myself better that's what I'm going to
do okay I think the chart is quite clear
it's quite simple but you can see
quickly what has happened historically
when we've had a recession and the FED
has pivot okay it's a bullish or bad if
I want to go through that in a minute
okay so you have in the chart The Gray
songs okay you can see that's rotation
so that for example here that's a gray
band here another gray band
so that's what I'm marking them for you
okay we're gonna go through them also
here you got another one I almost didn't
see this one okay so we're gonna focus
on these gray buns the moment that there
has been a recession because I think
that we all can agree
and even even the FED can agree because
they've said it multiple times that
there is going to be yam profession okay
they keep saying mild tradition well
we'll see about that but at least they
say that there is going to be a
recession okay even if they've changed
their meaning of recession a couple of
times but basically you know
um those gray bands they are they mean
in recession the blue is the price
action of the s p okay and this black
chart here these black lines does the
interest rates okay so you can see that
for example you know using this example
this is when they
are raised in the interest rates here
they pose for some months and then they
could write okay and you can see that
happens all the time you know again they
infrastrate they raise rates they pause
for some months then they drop okay that
pause is quite important because in this
example here that was I think around a
year and a half maybe but in this
example it was
a bit more that was you know a couple of
years I would say that was a couple of
years here
um in this example it was even less it
was barely the idea I would say
um this was immediately and I'm not
taking this example here
because there was no recession okay but
you can see here that really you know
the high grades then they hold in here
for some time they hike again then they
hold here for you know not many months
maybe I would say that video that this
was uh less than a year for sure and
then they could again the rates okay so
let me remove all these drawings from
here
okay the chart is clean now and we're
gonna go through it now okay so
basically we're expecting a gray band to
show here okay that's going to be a
recession
now let's go through all the cases with
rotation what happened when there was a
pause in in hiking rates and then what
happened when they could rate simple as
that we're gonna go through this example
here okay the most recent one so you can
see the
if we you know draw a line here
but of course if we draw it in a color
that we can see so maybe
let's do it
let's do it purple for example okay
so uh this was the moment
where they pause the rates and you can
see the sincere
is through that market
pumped okay you can see here the market
was going up but then you can see the
moment here when they could rate Market
Dooms aggressively okay and he almost
goes back to the same point so that's
what I'm telling you after the fat
pivots
you can expect that on site we're going
to go through it again you're going to
see the same thing okay this is when the
FED poses
okay then you see a rally
and then what happens when they put
rates yeah when they
um
pivot
well you can see that then Market drops
very aggressively in this case you can
see the 2008
profession you can't say the eye drops
you know a lot so again the fat pivots
the market crash we're gonna go through
it again another gray band here okay
what happened they rise here there was
no really a pause I mean it was a very
quick post so you can see that the
market here
um actually it pumped a bit you can see
okay pumped a bit but then you can see
that then they pivot
and that's when the market crashes again
and it takes it to the almost to the
starting point okay we'll go through it
again what happened here
this is when they pivot okay this is
when they post so uh in this time here
after we post if you notice they hold
they don't pump they don't even do
anything they assault and then you cut
here this dotted a red line you can see
that that's the pivot Market crosses
okay so it's as simple as that now there
is a Confluence there is a correlation
between Bitcoin up the SMP so
uh what can happen now of course it
depends for how long they want to pause
the rate but
I think it's quite safe to say that the
market
should either pump or hold with this
pause here okay so imagine here you have
this post here I don't know how long
it's gonna take I don't think it's gonna
take
several years I think I mean let's see
what Duran Paul has to say today I was
quite surprised when he said that
everyone I could write this year let's
see if he repeats it and if so uh if
it's not this year I think it's gonna be
at the start of next year they can
take that long to be honest so that's
what I think but what I mean guys is
that
we're gonna expect now the FED to post
right here and when they push right here
the SMP we need a hold here
or it can continue rolling okay and then
when you set the Fed pivoting
that's when you're gonna see the s p
dropping okay and this drop here
Bitcoin is going to fill it because
Bitcoin follows the SMP okay so that's
the bigger picture guys that's what I'm
telling you
and I can justify you why I say it don't
expect a bull market after the FED pivot
don't because history is telling you
that that doesn't happen history is
telling you that when the fat pivots and
they could rate
the SMP drops and Bitcoin is gonna
follow it in principle okay now
it's you know you can tell me
and I'll tell you yes you're right if
the FED pauses then you know it the SMP
is either gonna hold or continue in
rally because that's what has
historically happened and I agree with
you that's right Paul
once the fat pivots hits the fan
remember that we've had the most
aggressive hiking cycle of history and
something is gonna pray guys something
is going to break and remember that
those effects of those hikes they come
with Kuala delay we are not feeling them
yet and the FED has said that okay in
the previous fomc meeting they said that
um they're expecting to feel the effects
of the hikes
they haven't felt them yet those effects
so
that's what I mean guys the bigger
picture is telling you uh you can be
relaxed now the calm comes before the
storm and the storm is going to be that
pivot okay so uh that's what I want to
say guys uh be careful today
don't have any positions open especially
with high leverage because they're gonna
get stopped most likely for this one to
me wakes up down retraces false moves
it's going to be quiet while they at
least not what I'm expecting so I
wouldn't suggest you to do trade between
half past five okay this is
um of course UTC time that's 30 minutes
before the FMC meeting and then you have
the press conference
at half past six
that usually lasts between 30 and 45
minutes give it an hour so that would be
half past seven I would say that there
are today two hours
of not trading and that should be
between half past five and half past
seven so wait until at least half past
seven to start trading okay that's what
I would suggest you don't trade during
news announcements because you might get
wrecked okay guys so thank you so much
for watching
and I'll see you soon